all right so this is completely bonkers
according to some new data and some new
studies smoking cigarettes yeah it's
back in New York City let's look at some
info from 2002 to 2010 smoking among
adult New Yorkers decreased 35% that's a
lot from 22% of population to 14% and
that was the lowest recorded rate in
2013 the smoking rate rose to 16% and
for the first time ever since 2007 there
are a million smokers in New York City
now interestingly New York City has one
of the highest tax rates on cigarettes
it's about four dollars and thirty-five
cents a pack uh people are saying that
maybe because of budget cuts we're not
doing or New York City is not doing as
many anti-smoking ads and then that
causes more people uh to smoke um so I
just let's just start this with the
personal stuff did you guys ever smoke I
smoked two packs a day for 16 years Wow
and do you not smoke anymore I quit
smoking cigarettes about 20 years ago
okay cigars cigars hmm yeah occasions
babies yet buddies will you know they're
always there kids that's okay children
now yeah
I'm smoking cigars for grandchildren now
am ia jog what's after that what's the
next great grandchildren that's what
they have to stick the cigar in the
respirator just watch the valve fill up
a smoke in my chamber hey exit yeah uh
look we obviously know you like that one
uh look we know that smoking is no good
for you everyone knows it so I don't
necessarily buy the idea that because of
ads somehow not being run that people
are starting to smoke again uh what do
you what do you make of it like is this
some way the people are sort of taking
back power I always think it's something
like that you know like they so they can
exercise some control in their lives
when there's a lot of stressful [ __ ] out
there and you can in a depression yeah
we're in a depression we're calling it a
recession we're in a depression it's
harder to pay for everything and people
need to act like they're cool so that
they I think a lot of people think well
if I walk into a work setting looking
stressed they won't want to work with me
so I have to look cool have to go
outside do a thing make me look cool
when I walk back in I also think
a level of nihilism at work right now in
in the national zeitgeist I think it's
finally sunk in that global warming is
an issue that uh that pandemic is likely
at any moment and there's the real
feeling that we might be seeing some
sort of an end to civilization as we
know it and why am i denying myself this
minor pleasure over a few dollars tax
yeah when in fact the polar bears are
gone yeah you know the the the Arctic
ice is melting and I'm worried about
lung cancer I might get in 40 years
right how's that you think is actually
conscious with people because I think
the Congress I do think about that stuff
but then I'm like you know people always
thought the world was gonna end and [ __ ]
with always happening I wasn't yeah no I
think there's a real feeling of it now
that may or may not be true but I think
it's it's filtered into and it may not
be a conscious people aren't driving to
work on why am I going to work
the world's coming to an end but I think
at some level underneath there's this
feeling of geez I might actually live to
see how all this works out yeah you know
and and what do you do with that
information right that then you really
need a cigarette you know where the
record whole thing is watching to see
how this comes out yeah and I'm in the
fight I want to see how what what
happens next there it is the only thing
that keeps me from killing myself I want
to see how me there's too many graves
yet to piss on for me to go my parents
on the other had have been smoking uh
two packs a day each since they were in
their teens they are now both in their
mid to late seventies and they will not
die yet patience patience you'll see how
it all turns out do we need to get off
the cigarette you look everyone knows
cigarettes about you but we do play [ __ ]
that's been few and alcohols illegal for
some reason weed isn't and we know that
weed isn't bad for you basically absurd
we need to just get off the ante
cigarette been elected people do what
they want to do I mean that's my general
thing even with with harder drugs I mean
I think we should basically be
legalizing these things we shouldn't be
putting all these people in jail for
doing recreational stuff i cigarettes a
lot of people and I'll smoke a little
lights lighting up on the
and all red noses in the night you know
yeah if you have uh LED lights flashing
on your face you should be either having
a conversation over a Bluetooth or
joining the board collective yeah that's
how I buy last on this is they're saying
that living in New York City maybe that
is that this is specific to where the
smoking rates in the rest of the country
are dropping but part of being in New
York City is just being like [ __ ] you to
everything and I'm gonna live through
this the [ __ ] noise and the smells
and the sweat and the angry people so
it's like I'm gonna smoke and it sort of
goes to your point a little bit earlier
but I'm just gonna do what I had to to
get through the day it's possible that
even with the smoke in New York you're
actually getting better filtered air
that the pee smell yeah that'd be a job
you know what back to New York City
where I used to live a couple weeks ago
and the corner I've been back in about a
year and a half the corner that I lived
on always smelling a certain type of pee
and that smell is still there you're an
athlete that's not that's not right